- Now, when the police raided your place
the five people
they found in your freezer,
(suspenseful music)
did you cut them up too?
- God, that was a long time ago.
- People don't change.
I should know, my mom sent
me to gay conversion camp.
(laughs)
Amazing, that you ended up in minimum.
The Russian mob must've sprung
for one hell of a lawyer.
- You don't know a thing about me.
(speaking in foreign language)
- I come here to buy a boat,
not become some god damn pirate!
(laughing)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Please don't drop them.
- Out there, shake hands.
(speaking in foreign language)
- This is very important people.
- Go meet his wife.
- I've been cooking all day.
I smell like onions.
(speaking in foreign language)
- I have someone to make you acquaintance.
- The third time, the same thing happened.
And the farmer looks at his wife,
then back at the penguin
and finally the penguin goes,
(laughs)
he's not an eggplant man,
he is retarded.
(laughs)
You get it, 'cause he--
- We get it.
- My brother was retarded.
- I'm so sorry to hear that.
You know my husband's a little slow.
Says he was dropped on
his head when he was born,
just my luck, they couldn't have dropped
him on his dick?
(laughing)
- I think I slept wrong last night.
Should we call it a
short walk today ladies?
- Yeah.
- Awe, you barely broke a sweat.
- My son has dentist appointment.
- Oh, Okay.
- We're close to your house, no?
- Yeah, right over there.
Same time tomorrow?
- We'll let you know.
(light piano music)
(Russian style music)
(traffic honking)
- Oh no.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Red.
- And the penguin goes.
He's not an eggplant, he's retarded.
It's fucking funny!
- Is just not.
(speaking in foreign language)
on your head make me giggle though.
(laughing)
(intense music)
- You.
(all gasp)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Oh shit.
- What the fuck were you thinking?
After all Ganya's done for us?
He love those tits!
- He can get them back!
There's plenty more of
them at the tit store.
- Did you count to ten?
You supposed to count to ten!
- I never even wanted to speak to those
(word in Russian), you made me!
- Why did you do such a thing?
- Because they left me out!
Because they made fun of me!
Because no matter how hard you try,
and how much we want it,
there's the people who serve the bread
and people who eat the bread,
and for once it would be nice
if you would be on my side!
(crying)
(speaking in foreign language)
- How bad?
- They want $60,000.
- No boob job costs $60,000,
that's crazy.
(crying)
- This one does.
- I was, I was just,
they're so mean!
- So are the men they married.
They meaner.
- I'm sorry dear.
- Figure out something,
we always do.
(doorbell rings)
- Hello?
(subway whistling)
(speaking in foreign language)
- It's fine.
It will make things right for us.
- This doesn't feel right.
(speaking in foreign language)
- We're fine.
Work it out.
(speaking in foreign language)
(door slams)
(whistle blows)
(speaking in foreign language)
- It's not about the prices.
It's about the books.
- We have to move product regularly,
then and only then, we
can explain other income.
- Maybe you're not thinking big enough.
Restaurants come and go, yes?
Look at this place, every
week we almost close.
But not schools, not hospitals,
- Galya-
- All I'm saying is,
you get something big, something steady,
like the Italians have with the garbage,
then you're not out chasing bids.
My father, he sold candy.
Out of a box, everyday,
up and down the street.
He walked so much he
wore holes in his shoes.
Until one day, he passed by an army base,
right after the soldier's lunch time,
and he realized that all he had to do
was stand there and open his box.
He sold out in minutes,
so he did it again.
Day after day.
There were always soldiers,
there was always lunch, and
they always wanted candy bars.
No more holes in his shoes.
(speaking in foreign language)
(laughing)
- Anyway, our guy looked into the
government contracts
thing, schools, hospitals.
- Yeah?
- Looks like we'll be able
to work something out.
(speaking in foreign language)
- And now I complain to you.
- We can discuss that another day.
- I spoke to Olga again, she says these
retirement communities are only going
to keep popping up, if we
get in at the beginning.
- Sure, sure, next time
(speaking in foreign language).
- They can't wait five minutes?
I'm offering a gold mine here.
And it's not even illegal.
- They'll get excited
when they finally hear it.
- Every time they forget I'm
the one with the good ideas.
The prison contract?
That was me.
(speaking in foreign language)
So, meeting with the Serb.
You ready for that?
(Sighs)
- You think it's too late
to marry Sonja Chekova?
My mother thinks her dad
could get me into courses
at the gem society.
- You don't want to be a
diamond cutter at Zales.
And you don't want to live
next door to your mother.
That's the only reason mother
is nice to that stupid girl.
You can do better than Sonja Chekova
With her underbite.
- Last time we went out, the
guy didn't die all the way.
Vlad had to finish him with a tire iron.
- I don't want to know about these things.
- His eye popped out of
his head like a slinky toy.
- Maybe they have
another job you could do?
I could ask.
- No, I'm fine, I can handle it,
I don't know why I'm complaining.
- Good things come to those who stay late.
(car horn honks)
- Ah, that's me.
- Oh, your mother can wait!
Have you cookie!
- She'll yell at me, it's not worth it.
- Good night.
(melancholy piano music)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Are you ever going to let me speak?
- I might as well wait in the
freezer while the men talk.
If you don't want me to speak
up when I notice mistakes.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Keep him on look out,
have him run errands.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Get Donila or Constantine.
they're able to prove themselves.
That aren't such mama's boys.
(speaking in foreign language)
- (Sighs) I'm a mama, I know mama's boys.
The boys are at Uleyla's,
we could go out to dinner?
- What about Who Wants
To Be A Millionaire?
Don't you want to see
that college student win?
- What does he need a million dollars for?
They always think they
know, and guess and poof!
They never walk away.
- Not everyone is smart as my Galina.
(doors banging)
(speaking in foreign language)
- Inspectors come unannounced.
(sad downbeat music)
- Gali?
(gasps)